This lecture is about the
implementation of text retrieval
systems.
In this lecture we will discuss how we
can implement text retrieval method
to build a search engine.
The main challenge is to manage a lot of
text data and to enable a query to be
answered very quickly and to respond to
many queries.
This is a typical text retrieval system
architecture.
We can see the documents are first
processor via tokenizer to get that
tokenized units, for example words, and
then these words or tokens will be
processed by a indexer that would
create the index which is a data
structure for the search engine to use
to quickly answer query.
And the query will be going through a
similar process in step, so that
tokenizer would be applied to the query
as well so that the text can be
processed in the same way
the same units will be matched with
each other.
And the queries representation would
then be given to the scorer which would
use the index to quickly answer a users
query by scoring the documents and then
ranking them.
The results will be given to the user
and then the user can look at the
results and provide some feedback that
can be expressed judgments about which
documents are good, which documents are
bad or implicit feedback such as click
slows so the user doesn't have to do
any,
anything extra the user would just look
at the results and skip some and click
on some results to view.
So these interaction signals can be
used by the system to improve the
ranking accuracy
by assuming the view of the documents
are better than the skiped ones.
So a search engine system then can be
divided into 3 parts.
The first part is the indexer,
and the second part is a scorer that
responds to the users query, and the
third part is a feedback mechanism.
Now typically the indexer is done in
the offline manner, so you can
preprocess the collected data and to
build the inverted index which we will
introduce in the moment.
And this data structure can then be
used by the online module, which is a
scorer to process users query
dynamically and quickly generate search
results.
The feedback mechanism can be done
online or offline depending on the
method.
The implementation of the indexer, and
the scorer is fairly standard and this
is the main topic of this lecture.
In the next few lectures, the feedback
mechanism, on the other hand, has
variations
depends on which method is used.
So that is usually down in the
algorithm specific way.
Let's first talk about the tokenizer.
Tokenization is to normalize lexical units
into the same form so that semantically
similar words can be matched with each
other.
In the language like English.
Stemming is often used and this is
where map all the inflectional forms of
words into the same root form.
So for example, computer computation
and computing can all be matched to the
root form compute.
This way all these different forms of
computing can be matched with each
other.
Normally this is good idea to increase
the coverage of documents that matched
with this query, but it's also not
always beneficial because sometimes the
subtle of this difference between
computer and computation might still
suggest the difference in the coverage
of the content, but in most cases
stemming seems to be beneficial.
When we tokenize the text in some other
languages, for example Chinese,
we might face some special challenges
in segmenting the text to find the word
boundaries, because it's not obvious
where the boundary is as there's no
space to separate them.
So here, of course we have to use some
language specific natural language
processing techniques.
Once we do tokenization then we would
index the text documents and that is to
convert the documents into some data
structure that can enable fast search.
The basic idea is do pre-compute
as much as we can basically.
So the most commonly used indexes, is
called inverted index.
And this has been used to in many
search engines to support basically
search algorithms,
sometimes other indices,
for example, a document index might be
needed in order to support the
feedback.
Like I said, in this kind of techniques
are not really standard in that they
vary a lot according to feedback
methods.
To understand why we want to use
inverted index, it would be useful for
you to think about how you would
respond to a single term query quickly.
So if you want to use more time to
think about that, pause the video.
So think about
how you can preprocess the text data so
that you can quickly respond to a query
with just one word?
If you have thought about that
question, you might realize that what
the best is to simply create a list of
documents that match every term in the
vocabulary.
In this way you can basically pre
construct the answers.
So when you see a term, you can simply
just fetch the ranked list of documents
for that term and return the list to
the user.
So that's the fastest way to respond to
a single term query.
Now the idea of inverted indexes
actually basically
like that, we're going to pre construct the
such a index that would allow us to
quickly find the all the documents that
match a particular term.
So let's take a look at this example.
We have three documents here and these
are the documents that you have seen in
some previous lectures.
Suppose we want to create inverted
index for these documents.
Then we would maintain a dictionary in
the dictionary we will have one entry for
each term, and we're going to store
some basic statistics about the term.
For example, the number of documents
that match the term
or the total number of
frequency of the term, which means we
would count the duplicated occurrences
of the term.
And so, for example news.
This term ocurred in all the three
documents.
So the count of documents is 3.
And you might also realize we need this
count of documents or document
frequency for computing some statistics
to be used in the vector space model.
Can you think of
that? So
what weighting heuristic would need
this
count?
That's IDF, right?
Inverse document frequency.
So IDF is the property over turn and we
can compute it right here.
So with the document account here, it's
easy to compute the IDF, either at
this time or when we build index or
running time
when we see a query.
Now,
in addition to these basic statistics,
we also store all the documents that
match the news, and these entries are
stored in a file called postings.
So in this case it matched three
documents and store information about
these three documents
here.
This is the document ID, document one,
and the frequency is 1,
the TF is 1 for news.
In the second document, it's also 1 etc.
So from this list that we can get all
the documents that match at the term
news and we can also know the frequency
of news in these documents.
So if the query has just one word news
and we can easily look up this table to
find the entry and go quickly to the
postings and fetch all the documents that
match news.
So let's take a look at another term.
This time, let's take a look at the
word presidential.
This word occured in only one document,
document three, so the document
frequency is one.
But it occurred twice in this document,
so the frequency count is 2 and
the frequency count is useful in some
other retrieval method where we might
use the frequency to assess the
popularity of a term in the collection,
and similarly will have a pointer to
the postings here.
And in this case there is only one
entry here, because,
the term occured in just one document,
and that's here.
The document ID is 3 an it occured it
twice.
So this is the basic idea of inverted
index.
It's actually pretty simple, right?
With this structure we can easily fetch
all the documents that match a term and
this will be the basis for scoring
documents for a query.
Now sometimes we also want to store the
positions
of these terms.
So,
in many of these cases, the term occured
just once in the document, so there's
only one position.
For example in this case.
But in this case, the time occurred
twice, so we will store two
positions.
Now the position information is very
useful for checking whether the
matching of query terms is actually
within a small window of let's say 5
words or 10 words
or whether the matching of the two
query terms is in fact a phrase of
two words.
This can all be checked quickly by
using the position information.
So why is inverted index good for
fast search?
We just talked about the possibility of
using it to answer a single word query.
And that's very easy.
What about the multiple term queries?
Let's first look at the some special
cases of the Boolean query.
Boolean query is basically boolean
expression like this.
So I want the relevant document to
match both term A and the term B right?
So that's one conjunctive query?
Or I want the relevant documents to
match term a or term b.
That's a disjunctive query.
Now how can we answer such a query by
using inverted index?
If you think a bit about it would be
obvious cause we had simply fetch all
the documents that match term a, and
also fetch all the documents that match
term B and then just take the
intersection
to answer a query A&B or to take the
Union to answer the query A or B.
So this is all very easy to answer.
It's going to be very quick now.
What about the multi term keyword
query?
We talked about vector space model for
example and we would match such query
with document generated score and the
score is based on aggregated term
weights.
So in this case it's not a Boolean
query.
But the scoring can be acted out in a
similar way.
Basically, it's similar to disjunctive
Boolean query.
Basically, it's like a or b.
We take the union of all the documents
that match at least one query term,
and then we would aggregate the term
weights.
So this is a basic idea of using that
inverted index for scoring documents in general,
and we're going to talk about this in
more detail later, but for now, let's
just look at the question why
is inverted index
a good idea. Basically why is it more
efficient than sequentially just
scanning documents? Like, this is the
obvious approach.
You can just compute the score for each
document and then you can then score
them.
Sorry, you can then sort them.
This is a straight forward method, but
this is going to be very slow.
Imagine the web it has a lot of
documents.
If you do this then it would take a
long time to answer your query.
So the question now is why would the
inverted index be much faster it has to
do with the word distribution in text.
So here's some common phenomenon of
word distribution in text.
There are some language independent
patterns that seem to be stable.
And these patterns are basically
characterized by the following pattern
of few words, like the common words
the, a, or we occur very
frequently in text.
So they account for a large percent of
occurrences of words.
But mostly words would occur just
rarely.
There are many words that occur just
once, let's say in the document or once
in the collection.
There are many such singletons.
It's also true that most frequently
words in one corpus may have to be
rare in another.
That means, although the general
phenomenon is applicable or is observed
in many cases, the exact words that are
common
may vary from context to context.
So this phenomenon is characterized by
what's called Zipf's law.
This law says that the rank of word
multiplied by the frequency of the
word is roughly a constant.
So formally, if we use F(w) to denote
the frequency, r(w) to denote the rank of a
word, then this is the formula.
It basically says the same thing, just
mathematical term we will see is basically
a constant, right?
So as so there is also parameter Alpha
that might be adjusted to better fit
any empirical observations.
So if I plot the word frequencies in
sorted order,
then you can see this more easily.
The X axis is basically the world rank
and this is r(w), Y axis is a word
frequency or F(w).
Now, this curve basically shows that
the product of the two is roughly the
constant.
Now if you look at these words, we can
see they can be separated into three
groups.
In the middle it's the intermediate
frequency words.
These words tend to occur in quite a
few documents, but they are not like
those most frequent words
and they're also not very rare.
So they tend to be often used in
queries, and they also tend to have
high TF IDF weights,
these intermediate frequency words.
But if you look at the left part of the
curve.
These are the highest frequency words
they occur very frequently.
They are usually stop words like the, a, we,
of, etc.
Those words are very, very frequent.
They are in fact too frequent to
be discriminated and they are generally
not very useful for retrieval.
So they,
are often removed and this is called
stop words removal, so you can use
pretty much just the count of words in
the collection to kind of infer what
words might be stop words.
Those are basically the highest
frequency words
and they also occupy a lot of space in
the inverted index.
You can imagine the posting entries for
such a word would be very long, and
therefore if you can remove such words,
you can save a lot of space in the
inverted index.
We also show that the tail part, which has a
lot of rare words.
Those words don't occur very frequently
and there are many such words.
Those words are actually very useful
for search.
Also, if a user happens to be
interested in such a topic, but because
they're rare. It's often true that the
users are unnecessary
interested in those words, but retain them
would allow us to match such a document
accurately, and they generally have
very high IDFs.
So what kind of data structures should
we use to
store inverted index?
It has two parts, right?
If you recall, we have a dictionary and
we also have postings.
The dictionary has modest size,
although for the web it's still going
to be very large, but compared with
postings, it's modest.
And we also need to have fast random
access to the entries 'cause we want to
look up with a query term very quickly.
So therefore we prefer to keep such a
dictionary in memory if it's possible,
or if the collection is not very large,
this is feasible; but the collection is
very large,
then it's in general not possible if
the vocabulary size is very large.
Obviously we can't do that so, but in
general that's our goal, so the data
structures that we often use for
storing dictionary would be directly
accessed
data structures like hash table,
or B-tree if we can't store everything in
memory, we can use this and
try to build a structure that would
allow you to quickly look up
entries.
For postings,
they're huge.
And in general we don't have to have
direct access to a specific entry we
generate with.
Just look up a sequence of document IDs
and frequencies for all the documents
that match
a query term, so we would read those
entries sequentially.
And therefore, because it's large, we
generally have store postings on disk,
so they have to stay on disk.
And they would contain information such
as document IDs, term frequencies or
term positions etc.
Now, because they are very large,
compression is often desirable.
Now this is not only to save disk
space,
and this is of course one benefit of
compression.
It's not going to occupy that much
space.
But it's also to help improving speed.
Can you see why?
We know that
input and output would cost a lot of
time in comparison with the
time taken by CPU, so CPU is much
faster.
But IO takes time,
and so by compressing the inverted
index, the posting files will become
smaller and the entries that we have to
read into memory to process query time
would be smaller and then so we can
reduce the amount of trafficing IO and
that can save a lot of time.
Of course we have to then do more
processing of the data when we uncompress
the data in the memory.
But as I said in the CPU is fast, so
overall we can still save time.
So compression here is both to save
disk space and through speed up the
loading of inverted index.